thank you very much alex yeah that's
brilliant so i can see that now
thank you everybody and welcome to this
evening's
um executive meeting um so
start with um item one on the agenda
attendance is just no attendances and
i've already noted apologies from
councillor weston
are there any other apologies
no further apologies none reported to us
chair
thank you very much um okay moving on to
item two
um questions from members of the public
um i've been advised that we haven't
received any questions from members of
the public
um so moving on to item three
declarations of interest um are there
any declarations
of interest on tonight's agenda at all
not seeing any indication of any
declarations of interest
thank you um item four on the agenda
um minutes from the previous meeting
um i am happy to move those
minutes um do i have a second i'll
second for you kath thank you
thank you is that um approved approved
guy thank you um
and uh item five on the agenda matters
from um the scrutiny
committees um are there any matters
from scrutiny at all yeah can i get you
yes can i speak then chair um just just
briefly
the pandemic scrutiny committee has been
really busy
we we continue to get updates
on the councils and public health
and health generally and adult social
care and these updates have been
really informative
also we've had a update on children's
return
to school and progress in in the schools
along with other updates on homelessness
we've discussed the council's active
travel
which considered the cycle lanes etc
and at the last pandemic scrutiny
committee we considered the council's
response regarding the children's
services
ofsted reports of course we are
receiving regular updates on the
council's
council budget situation um
and we're formulating a report to
capture all of those issues to the
executive which we will send to you
within the coming weeks i i just wish to
remind the executive that the scrutiny
committee
have set up two uh special uh
dates to discuss the and scrutinize the
executive draft
budget and that they will be on the
first and the third
of december and lastly i would just like
to
thank the executive members and officers
for the support
they've given to scrutiny during this
very difficult time alongside
our partners that have come along
and give us great support as well but
particularly for
public health and so uh
that's just a few words from from from
me but
uh we are working very hard uh you know
to try to scrutinize as much as we
possibly
can but with the one committee that we
have and i think that is
you know obviously a bit of an issue in
itself
to be able to capture everything that we
feel that we need to look at at this
period of time so thanks for that chair
many thanks um councillor acton and i
would
like to also thank the members of the
pandemic scrutiny committee um for
all that you've done um over the the
last few
as you say challenging months um and
the officers as well who've been
involved in that process i think it's a
really
important and valuable process so thank
you for for the work
that's um that's that's happened and
that is ongoing
um moving on to um
item six on the agenda um this is a part
one
report um and there is a another repo
report in part two of the agenda
um and this is to um if
well i'd like to invite councillor patel
just to give um
a brief overview please um of the
approval to complete a community asset
transfer
um for the george h carl if you could
just give her an overview
of that thank you counselor thank you
chair
i'm very pleased to be able to present
this report to the executive
it's one that i consider to be a
positive story in these rather uncertain
times
this report updates from march 2020
when the executive gave in-principle
approval for a community asset transfer
of the george carnell centre
it marks a conclusion of a lengthy and
sometimes challenging period of
negotiations between
parties i would like to thank council
officers who have facilitated these
discussions
the george carnell community group who
have not wavered in their determination
or hard work
ward councillor barry wins stanley who
has helped support the process
and trafford leisure who have played a
key role over the last 12 months
i am proud that this report represents a
fulfillment of our administration's
commitment
to the users of the george carnell
centre and to residents of david hume
to explore and facilitate options to
keep the centre running as a leisure
facility
as this initial stage of this project
draws to a close
the approval of this report marks the
beginning of a new project phase
one which will require as much if not
more commitment to realize the ambitions
of relaunching george h garnell as a
community venue
just to draw some of the key points from
the report
this report asks for executive approval
to dispose of the george h carnell site
under a community asset transfer
to the george carnell community group
cic
it is proposed to do this through two
leases
one of 25 years on the building and
small car park
another of five years with potential to
extend after that
on the large car park site this will be
a disposal of council land
under value to support this disposal
a request that executive is asked to
note the business plan which we'll
discuss later in part two
to consider the risks involved to both
traffic council and george carnell
community group
and to delegate authority to corporate
directors to agree terms and complete
leases
in support of the community asset
transfer executive is asked to approve
the funding of immediate works of the
value of twenty three and a half
thousand
agree to funding of future major works
capped for two years up to the value of
fifty thousand per annum approval is
sought to agree a loan facility
of 96 000 pounds to the george carnell
community group
to support recruitment ict investment
and to cover utility and running costs
this report asked the executive to note
the business plan and key commitments
within that
to develop a centre that complements and
does not compete
with the refurbished and now
successfully operating move
ermstan set out today our ambitions to
develop a community-led health and
wellbeing centre that responds
and reflects local needs aligning
closely with council strategic
objectives around health and well-being
part two we'll look more closely at the
business case for this community asset
transfer
there are risks particularly around the
impact of covid
on the leisure industry and the leisure
market meaning forecasting income is
difficult
further to this the condition of the
building and identified long-term estate
investment
presents an ongoing financial commitment
to the george
group the council is making the
financial commitment set out in this
report but it is unlikely to be able to
offer further financial support in the
future
the granting of a 25-year lease to the
george carnell community group
will enable them to investigate external
funding opportunities
in conclusion the george carnell
community group should feel very proud
of themselves for getting to this point
i am under no illusions about the hard
work that lies ahead
there was overwhelming public support to
keep the george center open
and key to it to its success will be the
community getting behind it once again
i'm happy to take questions now chair
and again later as we consider part two
thank you
many thanks councillor patel and i echo
your words um about being incredibly
proud of this
um i'm not proposing to have to
lengthy um a discussion now there will
be further opportunity to
um to ask some questions but just to ask
members of the executive do you have any
any initial
um questions or comments
i'm not seeing any hands raised from
any members of the executive and so i
will invite questions
and i know there are a couple um from
members more widely as i say and there
will be a further opportunity to discuss
and we need to be
careful about what we do discuss in part
one of the agenda
um so counselor lam do you have a
question or comment i do deputy leader
thank you
very much indeed and i will uh confine
my
uh questions to part one of the report
mindful that uh the business
case is actually contained in part two
of the report
um i was a little bit disappointed that
councillor
patel might answer some of the
gaps that appear uh in the paper and to
which he has
in fact eluded but if we go back to
march you'll recall that uh i was
uh very supportive of this uh transfer
i think you know the community can do
amazing things and we all hope
for great success here and this is the
point
we really all want this to to work for
everybody
uh but you know to me there's a glaring
sort of
uh sort of contradiction in the report
the executive is being asked at
the set of recommendations on page 12
recommendation
seven uh you're being asked to agree
that the community interest group
business plan
is not competition for the leisure
center
at hermston and of course it's important
that you
believe that and agree that otherwise we
do have a bit of a problem
however the report at a number of stages
actually does refer to the problem
with uh competition and i think
you know you'll know where these places
are but i mean on page 19
uh
when i find it there is reference there
to um you know the possibility
possibility of competition i'm doing
this from memory now because i can't
find my exact paragraphs but on page 20
also there is a reference uh to
uh the business plan being a possible
source of competition
to ernst leisure center so
for me there's still a need to sort of
square that
up uh somehow so that we don't find
ourselves
uh with a community interest group
that's really struggling here
and a plan for the leisure company
of which the council is the key
and well only shareholder
actually struggling to meet its um
its business plan uh which of course is
for the for all residents
uh in trafford not just in uh dave yoon
uh and uh councillor patel has
has already alluded to some of the uh
weaknesses in the business plan
uh you know the 1.4 million
pounds capital uh that's needed to
presumably keep the roof on the place or
words to that effect you know there is
no mean sum
where is that realistically going to
come from
the lack at the moment of
an agreement with the manchester
foundation
trust for the rental of
those spaces which are equivalent to 41
000 pounds a year as i
well as i understand it from the plan
and of course the gym
membership which has been highlighted as
a possible weakness here as we all know
in this difficult
sort of time of code so there's
something to me that's suggesting here
we're going a bit premature
uh with this uh there are gaps er
you know not insignificant gaps in
the business plan and i would have
thought that what's really needed now
is an independent uh look
and there are a lot of people out there
whose speciality
is you know how well
leisure centers can perform in
communities
and i would have thought that the course
to that kind of
independent uh review would be
appropriate to this stage
thank you very much deputy leader thanks
um
council alam um i appreciate you you've
um provided quite a lot of
feedback there and i think there were
some
questions within that i think you know
you've
you've recognized that this is um that
there are some complexities
um without strain too far then into
um part two of the report which we do
need to be mindful
of i will invite um councillor patel if
there are any comments
um that we would like to make and and
perhaps if there are any
technical questions there and if richard
would want to pick up any of those it
may be
um council orlando that we might provide
some
feedback um further on in the agenda
um or it could be that we might come
back to you on on on some of the
issues that you've raised because
there's quite a lot of detail in what
you
um discussed there but i will just
invite counselor patel if there are any
comments you did want to make
i i just i mean in i'll just set off
with
um acknowledging um
that any competition to move ernst is
you know
we wouldn't want to see that and i and i
acknowledge that
um concern i do feel that the the george
group's business plan does offer
something different
from what they're doing at move
armstrong which is actually
really considering it closed nine days
after opening because of covid
they are doing extremely well at move
instant um i think it's a completely
unique offer in the borough and i can't
see that the george center can offer
um to sort of compete on on a level that
will impact on their on their income
the the george group the act the anchor
tenants and we are into part two a
little bit here so i'm going to
sort of hold back the anchor tenants
that they're looking at are not
able to be facilitated in our trafford
leisure centres
um the court space that will be lost
with george
it can't be replicated elsewhere um and
i think that that is one of their their
key assets that they can offer at the
george
um the ongoing um
estate costs yes they they are they are
a risk and that's why they've been
highlighted
the group in their business plan have um
accounted for
you know income that goes back into a
pot that is
reserved for these ongoing replays
they're also
very keen um to to now start
investigating external funding options
which aren't available to us as a local
authority
um to to put into that estate fund um
i mean i could bring richard do you have
any more comments about the ongoing
maintenance cost or any comment to make
there
excellent i think just just a couple of
comments on the on the ongoing
um maintenance costs yes we are aware of
the the challenge in the existing
building
that's one of the reasons why we are
offering the group a 25-year lease
because that generally
is a lease that gives you a better
opportunity to attract
external grants and as councillor patel
said a number of those are grants
that the council aren't able to access
ourselves and we do think and the group
themselves think there is a lot of
benefit
there and they are in discussions with
um spot england and they're also
talking to other community asset
transfer groups and what they have done
in order to attract and bring an
additional grant
on the on the competition piece and
again i think this is
is an important point it's the point
that we did reference specifically in
the report
the business case without getting into
the detail of it
which has been the part two does clearly
set out that they're wanting to di
differentiate themselves from trafford
leisure they're not
simply trying to pick up the old george
carnell and run the same service there's
much more of a community focused
um service different range of offer
and there are there are there are some
users in there who are unique to
to george carl that they are looking to
keep there and maintain and
enhance so i think we've identified it
but it's clear this this is something
different
to the trafford leisure offer and the
offer that was provided at george kernel
previously
thank thank you both for for that
response
um i have got a few people who are
wishing
to speak i've got a counselor blackburn
councillor evans and councillor
but so um if we could just limit please
the
um the the amount of time we spend on
asking the questions
just for the uh the sake of the the
agenda
um and we can always follow up if if if
there's anything else that we um
we need to ask so can i bring in
counselor blackburn please
thank you deputy leader my question is
regarding um
the estate's considerations and the
larger
sorry the smaller car park has a longer
lease the larger
car park is initially they say for five
years
who's going to be actually responsible
for ensuring
that all detritus including numerous
strewn nitrous
oxide canisters are removed from site on
a regular basis
as rubbish impacts on the local
community
and will monies for for the
maintenance of said car parks
will that be a separate budget or will
that come out
of the budget for cleansing and
maintaining highways
in the daily home east ward thank you
thank you uh councillor patel did you
have a
a response to that at all i mean
um you know litter and those awful
nitrate
canisters are a real nuisance so you
know acknowledge that that concern there
um richard do you have um
a sort of a view on the anchor i know
it's the group isn't it that take the
maintenance and the responsibility for
the cleansing
do we have a plan for the ongoing
funding of that
so that that's something that the group
themselves will need to consider so the
responsibility under the lease lies with
the the group in the way that previously
responsibility lay with
trafford leisure so it doesn't come out
of the council's highways budget or our
street cleaning or grounds maintenance
budget
and it doesn't and it hasn't done
previously either
could i just suggest chair and what you
know if if we get approval
um except today it would be um
wonderful for councillor to blackburn i
know you probably have met with the
george group but they'd be really keen
to
to reconnect with with local councillors
there and perhaps that's something that
you can discuss with
with them um directly okay thank you
thank you
uh yeah it's a it's an important point
uh
councillor evans please thank you
councillor hines excuse the
uh no video i'm a limited bandwidth um i
i don't quite understand the split of
the car park so it will either need the
car park or it or it won't and obviously
so far it has needed it are we intending
perhaps spin it off and building on that
on a later date hence we've
hived it off to a five-year lease what
what's the intention i don't
understand that
ansel patel it was retained we'd
we had always put into the report that
um
we were retained um part of the um
the car park mainly to allow access to
maintenance and the public to the green
space behind it on kingsway park
we also require some large pieces of
land
for our covet response um
potentially down the line perhaps but
there are no
current plans and i haven't seen any
plans to develop that site
so for now um it will be leased to the
george group with a view to negotiating
a potential extension of that lease in
five years time
so it's a little air a little woolly
that we could have done right away to
access to the green we could have
written that into the lease
does seem and and the covid
that they would have allowed that
absolutely and it seems a little woolly
that and it seems
perhaps disingenuous and to be put in it
that way they could have easily been
caveated any lease
[Music]
okay thank you i'm sorry if uh council
evidence think
thinks i'm being disingenuous i'm just
stating now that there are no
plans to develop any part
of the uh george carnell
site currently thank you thank you for
that
absolutely thank you uh councillor patel
um and uh councillor but please
thank you sir um i want to speak this on
in principle actually because i don't
believe this has been well thought out
i don't believe transferring the george
carnell to
leisure sent it to community group is a
viable option
it has no prospects as a
self-sustainable administration
or covering operational costs
it's already dubious pro prospects for
developing and broadening its appeal are
untenable under conditions of completion
a competition against the armstrong
center
what are the consequences if the
trafford taxpayer-backed funding loan of
around a hundred thousand pounds
to the community group has to be written
off
who is underwriting the law will it be
another letter
from the leader to the government
blaming them for our exponential debt
growth
under the guise of kovind 19.
the recommendations including spending
another hundred thousand pounds over two
years
till december 2022 on major works to the
g's
the george carnell building i mean what
major works are they
has any current revaluation being made
of the trafford taxpayers priorities
for the george carnell center weighed
against the relative size
need or intensity of use by any user
group
when huge sums of track taxpayer traffic
taxpayers backed
loans and funding are to be diverted by
this administration's
approval of an unsustainable and high
risk
it's no longer a local issue
in the cold light of a changed reality
and priorities
this scheme must be withdrawn in the
interests of traffords
taxpayers and the greater good this
project should be withdrawn to
re-evaluate the strategy
that's how i feel about it thank you
um well i can assure you uh councillor
bot
um that this has been thought out and is
the product
of extensive work um and research
and actually extensively
um in in communication and consultation
with the community we all know that the
previous
administration um wanted to close that
center
and the community wanted um that center
to
um to remain open as a community asset
um councillor patel do you have a
response at
all to that well i'm i'm very sorry to
hear you know
counselor but feel so very negative
about about what
has the potential to be a wonderful
community asset
in the davey hume area i mean i i want
bit before my time but i'm wondering if
if we felt the same about stretford
public call which has
proven again and again its value to the
local community
there are risks and they're clearly
outlined in the report
and mitigated against in part
i have every faith in the george carnell
community group they're a wonderful
group of people
they've been we've been through a very
difficult um
circumstances with covid and they just
simply haven't wavered from their
absolute determination to make this
happen
not just for them but for the community
of david hume who will benefit and the
taxpayer will benefit
if we can make people healthier uh
staying out of hospital and
not not relying on our demand-led
services
it's very negative and i'm really very
disappointed i wish
the george carnell community group every
success and i
for one will be getting right behind
thank you uh councillor patel um i
echo those thoughts um okay
so um thank you for for those
questions and comments um i'm going to
move us um onto the next agenda item
um which is the fair price for care
uh council harding did you want to um oh
just before i do actually i think the uh
that that report that we've just heard
is for
noting at this stage with us to take the
recommendations into part two is that
right
uh jane can i just confirm that
yes that's absolutely correct yes thank
you thank you so
um yes so it's been for noting is that
noted
it is noticed thank you and so i am now
going to move us on to uh the next item
on the agenda which is
a fair price for care um and councillor
harding did you want to move both of
your papers
um together yes i will thank you
councillor heinz
um so i'm seeking the execs approval to
proceed to consultation
on the two papers that are before you
this evening so the recommendations are
that we proceed to consultation
you will note that each year the council
consults on the fair price for care
where we look to
amend um an uplift to home care
and to nursing and residential care it
should be noted that
we are still working out the dates for
consultation so we'll make those known
as soon as we have established those
dates
and they are proposals and not final
decisions that are laid out
in the report one thing i would just
like to say as i move these um reports
really is that
now more than ever i think we we owe a
huge debt of gratitude
to the social care workforce and sector
and this council remains committed to
the principles of the unison ethical
care charter
which we are determined to to seek to
raise pay
for staff across social care to raise
standards
to raise the quality of care and in
doing that we certainly will improve
outcomes for people that rely on home
care and in fact
what we've seen throughout covid is but
is by using
rapid home care we've managed to keep
more people safe and well at home
not having people in hospital but we
know that there's much more work to do
so without without more and there's not
more to say really because i think as
i've said it is a consultation
and as we move through the consultation
then i'm very happy to
move the reports that will have the
outcomes of those consultation but for
now i'm asking the exec to approve these
papers so that we can proceed
thank you thank you
councillor harding um are there any
comments or questions from members of
the executive
you're not seeing any um any questions
or comments
more broadly
again um i don't think i'm seeing any
questions or comments there um so the
reports
are um for approval to move to
consultation are they
approved
thank you um okay so moving on to
um item eight uh the licensing
act um can i move to
councillor freeman please
thank you deputy leader the council are
required to prepare
consult on and publish a statement of
licensing policy every five years
and our last review was in 2016.
the summary section outlines the five
main purposes of the policy
as a result of consultation between the
29th of june
and the 18th of september changes in
legislation and best practice
our policy has been updated some
features of the update
are ensuring local ward councillors are
consorted upon applications for new
premises licenses
or full variation applications expanded
detail
on measures to promote the licensing
objectives
a section on child sexual exploitation
promotion of a reduced
strength strategy expectations for
white-collar boxing events
counter-terrorism measures guidance on
the immigration act
and details of a pre-application
consultation service
the review has also considered whether
or not to keep cumulative
impact areas for ultraman and cell town
centres
this form part of the consultation such
an area is a designated zone
where evidence has indicated that the
number type or
density of licensed premises is
impacting adversely
on licensing objectives namely crime
disorder
public safety public nuisance and the
protection of children from harm
originally a concept cell and altering
were designated in our policy in 2016 as
such
places and now form part of what is
known as our special saturation policy
the police and crime act 2017
giving cumulative impact areas a legal
footing
as a result of the consultation and the
very fact the saturation policy has
never been used
to object to the grant or variation of a
premises license application in either
sale or
altering them a new statement of
licensing policy
removes the special licensing policy on
cumulative impact
for both ultragum and sale this is the
most significant
change to the policy from 2016.
the executive is asked to note the
content of the report
and the executive is asked to recommend
to full council approval of the revised
statement of licensing policy
at appendix f and before i finish and
take questions can i take this
opportunity to thank joanne boyle
our licensing team leader for her work
on this policy thank you deputy leader
thank you councillor freeman um
are there any questions or comments from
members of the
executive
i'm not seeing any um
and more broadly i have a
counselor evans please
that must be an accident and i apologize
no i'm not
no comment no problem um counselor
blackburn is your hand raised to comment
on this
item yes
deputy leader thank you i just wanted to
ask
um with regard to licensing of premises
a lot of um retail uh
premises old shops are sort of turning
into small
small bars and a lot of these
are closer to schools
than than you know say that the larger
pubs were in the past
will will um will anything be done to
control
the numbers of licensed premises close
to
schools in the future is that with that
with councillor freeman comment as to
whether or not that that'll be
um looked at um you know with with
regard to
um protection child protection issues
and you know things such as that thank
you
thank you councillor batman uh
councillor freeman would you like to
to touristy yes uh thank you deputy lead
i'll certainly comment on that
uh i think the the report was clear that
the uh when we consider
applications for licenses we consider
the licensing objectives namely crime
disorder public safety public nuisance
and the protection of children from
harlem however i have to say to
councillor blackburn
the very fact a bar is near a school is
never going to
disqualify that place from actually
getting a license
uh unless of course we can we can
evidence
uh that that one of the objects that one
of the license objectives is adversely
affected by it
um the saturation policy which we've
taken out of the policy what i will say
to you is we have renewed
public state public space protection
orders right across
southern alternate so this is that is to
prevent the drinking of alcohol in the
street and that's been one that has
worked
very effectively for us over the over
the uh over the last few years but
just because someone wants to open a bar
near a school he's necessarily going to
disqualify
that place from being granted a license
as simple as that thank you deputy
leader
thank you uh councillor freeman um
but as you say these are these are
factors we would always look
um to protect uh children when looking
at licenses um thank you
okay so the report is for
the noting and um for approval to take
forward to
uh council is it noted and uh approved
i thank you very
much um moving on now
to um item
nine on the agenda uh the council tax
support scheme and council of ross
please
thank you and this is another item that
comes up annually and it's a legal
requirement to formally approve the
council's local cts scheme before the
start
of each financial year obviously
at present we're seeing more people need
this support
and it's our intention as an executive
to recommend that council adopt the
council tax support scheme currently in
operation
um and aside from the updates and
national benefits so that's all i'm
i'm happy to take questions on that but
um yeah i'm i'm pleased to
exactly recommend recommending no change
to the scheme this year
many thanks counselor ross um are there
any questions or comments from members
of the executive
i'm not seeing any um any questions or
comments
more broadly please
um and council reverends is that your
hand up again
it is actually up now yes thank you um
i'd just like to uh show and normally
with uh councillor myers who uh can't
make it today i can i just i would like
to
support this policy we support it every
year it's needed and so you've got our
group support on this thank you very
much
thank you councillor evans um so the
report um it can can we um approve the
recommendations on page
one of the report please
thank you very much um and
staying with you i think councillor ross
um
it's the progress review for uh the
recovery update please
thank you again i'm delighted to present
the an update on our recovery program
activity
and since the onset of a pandemic in
march
i'd like to draw your attention to
section section five of the reports
which sets out in more detail
um the activities that have taken place
and i'd like to put on record my thanks
to
the entire staff of our the council who
have
worked tirelessly um since the pandemic
started in in march and really it's a
tribute to them all those actions that
are in the report
you know that they've managed to um to
put those forward and implement them so
thank you very much from me
for that uh section seven sets out the
challenges and
one challenge includes having to be
flexible between
recovery and response and um
i'd very much suggest given the um the
recent um
changes to restrictions and also the um
infection rates that we're we're heading
back into a uh
a response stage of um of of the uh the
pandemic sadly
um we've also got to be mindful of the
financial situation as well
which continues to be a a pressure and a
concern for us but happy to take any
questions on the paper
thank you uh councillor ross and i echo
your words um with regards to the amount
of
work um that's ongoing and i think the
report
talks about how our people are our
greatest asset and how hard they
they have worked and and that's
absolutely the case um are there any
questions and comments from members of
the executive
i'm not seeing any i don't think i yes i
am
councillor freeman please uh thank you
deputy leader i just want to support
exactly what council ross has said
in my own portfolio area i'm aware of
some outstanding work that has been done
by staff particularly in environmental
health
in licensing and against a very very
difficult backdrop
and and i think that you know we all
should be
very very grateful for the work they've
undertaken we have some absolutely
fantastic council staff
and we couldn't have delivered what
we've done so far without them
and they deserve a pat on the back and
our absolute
support thank you very much deputy
leader
agreed councillor freeman and thank you
for those
comments um i've got councillor coggins
please
thank you deputy leader and yes i want
to uh echo councillor ross's
um thank you to all the um all the staff
i'm sure i've put a lot of work into
this and there is there is a lot to
welcome in it
and but actually as i read i i became
increasingly worried
and and i'm afraid that i i feel that it
betrays the um the same attitude to the
climate crisis that we've seen in in
other in other
discussions here and by being more or
less absent from the report
so as we're trying to work out our
recovery plans
and i suppose what is um a time when
we're looking at how we can change
things to increase
our our quality of life our health and
well-being for our residents
and trying to tackle the other problems
we have and there is
and no mention the word climate doesn't
appear in this document
and i think carbon neutrality is
mentioned once as an add-on along with
air quality
and in 7.1 where we look at the key
challenges we're facing
there's no mention of the fact that
we've been told that we have to cut
our carbon emissions by 13
every year not once every year
and i does the exec not consider that
challenging or
um i mean we can go further if that's
not challenging enough
and just in section 5.3 where we look at
sustainability and economic achievements
there's again
no sustainable achievements and actually
borrowing the a56
lanes on here there is actually nothing
mentioned in the achievement section
and that is really relevant to to the
enormous challenge we're facing
now i know the last three months have
been difficult but
the laws of physics don't take that into
account um
in section 2.4 where our key objectives
are listed
our keeping within our new carbon budget
is not mentioned
and and um there's a strong focus also i
see on economic uh sorry inclusive
growth and despite the fact that our own
inclusive growth board is considering
moving away from this terminology
and there's widespread acceptance now
this terminology does not
take into account the uh important
environmental concerns
and as well the fact that of course um
more and more
uh groups campaigning for poverty and
for uh social justice are saying that
actually growth
is one of the key factors causing our
inequality and
and other problems and so i really would
like if we could see the
terms uh inclusive economy used instead
of inclusive growth which takes these
these issues into account and so really
i suppose i find myself reading this and
thinking this is not the work of a
council that intends or even
is considering making 13 cuts next year
you let alone every year
this is not reading like the document
from a council that is intending to make
to be honest one percent cuts in our
carbon emissions next year
and i don't want to be too hard i
understand what difficult situation
we're in
but the fact is that if this is the
document it's going to guide us out of
this
into our new way of living taking
advantage of the few benefits that have
come from the lifestyle changes that
we've we've made
looking for ways to save money and to to
have a healthier
happier population at the same time then
we really have to be
putting this at front and center and
really making this the focus
thank you um councillor coggins i'm
going to
um i'll bring councillor ross in
um first if you have a response that and
i know councillor rad's head
would also like to um to respond to that
and i think that may be indicative
of the fact that perhaps um the
uh that this report um is not
our only report clearly that comes to
council and that
council and or the executive and there
are lots of documents which do detail
the work that we um are progressing in
all of those areas that you've
highlighted but i'll bring
councillor ross in please thank you very
much deputy leader and um
thank you councillor coggins i have to
say i am disappointed
by that contribution councillor
cockington you know that i've got
a lot of time for you and a lot of time
for what you have to say there's been
many times
in the past where we've we've been in
agreement but this this paper is a
response
to a health emergency
and it is comprehensive in the way that
our officers have responded to the
pandemic
and continue to respond to the pandemic
i do think it's important to recognize
everything
that has gone in there and be mindful of
the fact that
the climate emergency will be addressed
through other reports and our
actions will be monitored through every
other report
but i wouldn't want our officers who we
all are aware have been working
flat out since march to um to meet some
very high challenges and demands
to feel as if their actions aren't
appreciated by this council
i know that my other colleagues will
come in now but i just have to say i am
disappointed by that response counselor
coggins i'm i'm sorry but
that is that is what i want to say at
the moment
thank you councillor ross um councillor
rad said please
thank you uh deputy leader uh i can say
is that
i'm i'm very surprised and shocked by
the comments from councillor collins
there
uh i mean obviously did we see reports
at the previous executive
on the start of the work we're doing on
climate change and i also attended a
meeting at gm level board
on friday and a lot of stuff is getting
underway
that obviously isn't being reported
properly yet that some of those meetings
will be made public
uh moving forward and there is an
actually an awful lot going on i think
we do need to publicize it better
i'm sure how we're doing it's just we're
doing nothing again is wrong before we
set out last month
so some of the things we are doing
locally that are all contributing to
that work
so that is actually uh so i'm certainly
making a project and i want to check all
the words of my colleagues
uh mike freeman and tom ross that in the
situation when our staff are doing an
amazing job there
so the dilemma we've got here is that do
we forget about the pandemic
actually concentrate on things like
climate change and ignore people's
health and well-being and those of
their staff who are trying to deliver
services under debit challenging
circumstances
often says from my position very
strongly that i will be working hard
every day i'm discussing i discuss
climate change only this morning in a
meeting
as well as being in a session virtually
a lot of friday and
earlier in the week so it's very much
our agenda but first priority
will be the health and well-being of our
staff during this pandemic and i'd like
to colleagues certainly make no
apologies for that i'm really sorry that
you don't find that an acceptable
position thank you debtor leader
thank you uh councillor radzad so the
report
is for um noting is it is it noted
i i sorry deputy leader can i come back
i think my
point has been misinterpreted oh okay
i did leave my hand up and put a comment
in the thing so i didn't want to
to intervene um my point was nothing to
do with the hard work of staff which i
acknowledged and thanked them for i
think you'll find my point is about a
political decision
that actually attacking the climate
emergency needs to be one of the key
objectives are listed in this document
that's my point it's a political point
about the direction the executive is
taking
and i really didn't want to be
misinterpreted as any sort of criticism
of the staff
whose work i appreciate and i regularly
thank thank you
and and i think i'd come back um
on that just to say that politically um
this is everything that you've outlined
is absolutely a key priority for the
executive
that it isn't that in this particular
report
which actually addresses um other
incredibly important
issues is not an indication of how
important this is to the executive we
have as councillors
as said and council of us we have
brought
lots of different reports to the
executive which do outline all of the
things that we're doing
um to to address those points and so
thank you for that um so yes the the
report is for noting
and and and i think we've had agreement
there that it is
noted um so moving on to
um any urgent business i've not had any
indication that there is any urgent
business
um so i'm now going to move to item
12 which is the exclusion resolution
um which i will move the exclusion
resolution which presumably means
um that we will move to
yes thank you
councillor freeman um i presume that
means that we move to now switch off the
webcast so that we can move to part two
of the agenda
let's give a few seconds please i'll
just make sure we're offline and i'll
let you know when we're okay to proceed
thanks a lot thank you very much